back in the media spotlight since being
twice convicted and twice acquitted of
killing Meredith Kercher and emotional
Amanda Knox has returned to Italy for
the first time in nearly a decade and is
speaking at a conference on criminal
justice in Modena where she remembered
her father visiting her in prison I
[Music]
begged I prayed that he saved me even
though he was as powerless as I was and
he had to tell me what my lawyers had
told him that it was probably going to
be years before I had another chance at
freedom it was a case that captured the
world's attention
amanda knox was accused of killing her
housemate Meredith Kercher who'd come to
Perugia to study the 21 year old was
found under a duvet with multiple stab
wounds
Rudy grey day was convicted of her
murder and sexual assault and Knox spent
four years in prison with her
ex-boyfriend after initially being
convicted of the murder but in 2015
Italy's highest court overturned the
decision in a definitive ruling Knox
previously said that she'd like to meet
Meredith Kercher's family and visit her
grave but today the coach's lawyers told
the Guardian that all B's insistence 'iz
and appearances are only ever done to
keep the attention on herself they went
on to say the murder is a tragic memory
for the Kircher family they lost their
daughter and sister in such a terrible
way it's also an injustice for them as
they still don't know the full truth
posting on Instagram before returning to
Italy knock stroke that she needed to
hang in there and felt frayed but more
than a decade since Amanda Knox was
first accused of killing her friend the
31 year old still attracts media
fascination and controversy in a trip
that's been seen as insensitive to the
memory of Meredith Kercher Ali Fortescue
Sky News